des jeunes à l'entraînement ou en
compétition l'image est forcément
antérieures à la crise du coc vide
elle va pourtant redevenir d'actualité
prochainement suite à la décision
gouvernementale de permettre aux mineurs
de retrouver le chemin de leurs clubs
sportifs la réaction a été à plutôt
positive de mon côté puisque ça va
permettre de pouvoir ré entraîner nos
jeunes assez rapidement il y aura des
interrogations de la part des parents
c'est tout à fait légitime
on essaiera de répondre le mieux
possible à ces interrogations
maintenant il faut avoir les les
recommandations du ministère pour
pouvoir leur répondre clairement
car aucune date précise n'a été annoncée
pas plus que les consignes sanitaires à
respecter ce qui ne facilite pas à
l'anticipation des professionnels du
secteur une reprise oui mais pour la
ville de tours cela ne suffira pas à
redonner un second souffle au club
c'est une première bonne nouvelle on
attend la confirmation quand même on a
des dates hypothétique
donc moi j'avance sur du solide du
fiable aujourd'hui on est en plein
brouillard l'angle économique du sport
et totalement niés dans ce plan de
relance
la perte de 15 % de licenciés
c'est 260 millions d'euros de recettes
en cotisations en moins pour les clubs
français
ça c'est pas du tout compenser en
réponse à la perte de licenciés subies
par les clubs
emmanuel macron a promis un pass'sport
en 2021
une aide financière pour inciter les
jeunes à la pratique sportive
mais là encore les contours de cette
annonce reste à définir